hello and welcome to this video ever
mock why as the opponent no name but i
played him a couple of times six games
then going for the London system here
okay it's going for Queen B 6 hmm yeah I
guess I'll just cover it and place see
for next I'm not a huge fan of playing
the London system with c3 age three and
stuff if you play it you should at least
try to earn yeah get an an active set up
as active as possible hmm i wonder if no
i was thinkin playin a three year maybe
but night h5 is no threat anyway and
Bishop g4 also doesn't feel very
threatening yeah I was thinking he would
go to f5 anyway hmm yeah okay I think
age 3 now is in order allow for Bishop
h2 and my general idea is yeah I will do
that now hmm i don't know let's let's
drop this back first let's not play play
c5 so early okay
I'm interesting an interesting thing
yeah i can if i take he might take with
the pond though not no no phone takes 92
and got c5 coming so that's not good i'm
thinking i was thinking 95 here could be
an interesting idea trying to ask this
this bishop where is some intending to
go yeah thinking g4 evening is that a
move g4 you didn't have many squares
something like age six looks wrong I
think yeah so this is big this is where
he goes and now i can try something
interesting and then F for this is now
threatening to kill his bishop with g5
he has to be very very um circumspect
now so that he doesn't get g5 played on
him
maybe we can even consider to go g5
himself this is really a threat if I get
in G fire okay now as bishop is killed
the question is can he somehow improve
his Bishop position okay I can do that
just annoy him a little bit then they
try it's not strictly necessary I don't
want to play for checkmate here at the
moment I just want to keep his bishop
out of the game currently he's totally
tied up with his pieces you can
absolutely not move them and now I have
to have to open up the position of
course a form yeah cannot allow our
complete um yeah shut down off of
everything so how to do that now I guess
Luke cheeks I'm basically playing with
extra material here so what is the best
way to do this here maybe that looks
counterintuitive putting it back but I
just want to trade stuff yeah if I trade
is rook the only piece that can move
what is he doing here and he cannot
seriously take on a one now I mean he
has to but this is just lost his pieces
are completely boxed in he cannot move
them yeah it's it's over just to win
black resigns yeah yeah yeahs to
absolutely that's a very nice example of
over over the doomed piece yeah here and
this in this position and for he has to
I mean probably it's already too late
but he has to do something quickly about
this g5 move I would
even consider to go g5 myself Ian just
to make sure that this scenario is not
happening and this is good however for
wide exposition Proteus is already quite
quite bad yeah and after g5 I think this
is almost winning here all yes to do
something drastic sacrifice one or two
points to even get some kind of play
with this is passive play yeah it's it's
it's basically over now I'll tell you
for now the engine is on plus two it's
kind of funny and here plus 4 and
probably climbing yeah he's got he
cannot move any of his pieces it's quite
funny really engine suggests this move
after which I just stayed and yeah what
now what move now and King age 7 I go I
can also pick up pick up material him
yeah it's a very instructive home
situation here with that g five more
it's it's important to understand that
this Bishop cannot get out ever yeah it
can go to f8 wet bites on that pawn and
the only way for them to somehow move it
yeah it's like II 5 I take he goes e 6
and bishop ave and this costs too much
material yeah so this is probably
strategically almost winning also the
night on d 7 will never find it with
square it would be a different story of
the night somehow had the ability to go
to f5 and that still keeps the bishop in
tuned but yeah but night it's not coming
there I mean there is a theoretical
route like here here and so on but that
takes a long while and it's still again
it doesn't solve the bishop issue yeah I
was a nice one thanks for watching